you're listening to an encore
presentation of Bible answers live
however if you want to order any
materials offered during tonight's
program you may call our resource number
anytime at
[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact in July 2018 a
man with the longest fingernails in the
world finally got a manicure sheet our
chill-out 82 from Pune India had his
nails cut off during a ceremony in New
York after letting them grow out for 66
years
Jalal holds the Guinness world record
for the longest fingernails on one hand
he was first inspired to see how long he
could grow out his nails on his left
hand back in 1952 when he was 16 years
old a teacher had scold with him for
accidentally breaking one of her
fingernails
according to chow the teacher lectured
him about the level of care required to
grow up nails and said he would never
understand unless he experienced it for
himself so he did according to Guinness
World Records in November 2014
Salah fingernails were measured and
found to have a combined length of 29.8
feet with his thumb being the longest at
78 inches that's like six-and-a-half
feet
chilao traveled from India to New York
City to have his nails removed where the
Ripley's Believe It or Not museum where
they will be forever displayed it's not
known whether or not he was compensated
or how much for his extraordinary nails
it allows decision to remove his epic
fingernails was partly influenced by the
constant level of care required to
maintain them understandably it's hard
to sleep at night or do anything with
your hand burden with 10 pounds of
fingernails do you know the Bible talks
about a man who had extremely long
fingernails
stay with his friend we'll talk about it
on this edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 spoke page and
join us live and you could even text in
some questions if you'd like so the
number for today's program eight hundred
four six three seven two ninety seven
will bring you into the studio that's
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven my name is doug batchelor
my name is john ross good evening
listening friends and pastor Doug as you
always do let's start with prayer dear
father in heaven we thank you that we
have this opportunity to open your word
and study together we want to ask your
blessing and your presence be with us
here in the studio and be with those who
are listening across the country in
around the world and we place this time
in your care in Jesus name Amen amen
well pastored I hope at the program by
talking about an individual that it's
just amazing to think about that my
fingernails just start getting a little
long and they start bothering me and I
have to cut my fingernails how can
someone live with fingernails that
hadn't been cut for what did you say 60
years 60 60 years yes yeah I know with
me if I if my fingers they all start
getting along they break how does a guy
keep his fingernails from breaking off
when they're that long for that many
years is just pretty remarkable but you
know what it made me think of is the
story in the Bible where it tells us
that Nebuchadnezzar because of his pride
he had this dream of a big tree and he
called Daniel and to help him understand
this and Daniel said you're that tree
that's gonna get cut down and humbled
because
of your pride and your selfishness and
he admonished Nebuchadnezzar the King to
humble himself and for a while he had
about a year of tranquillity and then he
became proud again and he's looking at
Babel and he said no this is my Babel
and I've built it for my majesty and and
suddenly his wisdom and his mind was
taken from him and he became like a
raving animal and they didn't know what
to do with the King they didn't want the
rest of the nation to know that the King
had gone berserk and they kind of put
him out to pasture and the Bible says
that his hair grew long like I think one
version says like feathers and other
version like the lion's mane totally
unkept and his nails grew long like
birds claws and it all came upon him
because of his pride and his inability
to humble himself now at the end of
seven years God restored his reason he
finally saw what had happened to him he
realized it's only the Spirit of God
that gives us the ability to do anything
so often we take credit for whatever we
accomplished and what can we do without
the Lord what talents do we have without
God's help there's nothing that we have
that God hasn't given us that's what the
Bible says but that's the biggest battle
we all wrestle with is the surrender of
self and we have a free book we're
making available tonight and it's a very
important book on there one of the
Christian attributes of humility and how
to surrender yourself to Jesus it's free
well that's the title it's called the
surrender of self and that's our free
gift to anybody who'd call and ask the
number to call is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven you can
ask for the book called the surrender of
self we'll be happy to send it to
anybody who calls and asks oh you can
also go to the amazing facts website and
we have a free online library and you're
able to read the book there if you can
call but again that number is 885 six
seven four seven that is the resource
phone line you might want to jot that
down we're gonna give you some
additional resources throughout the
program but you can ask for the special
gift tonight called the surrender of
self very important principles found in
the book really essential for one
salvation and if you have a Bible
question our phone line here to the
studio is eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven that's one eight
hundred
says for 63 72 97 our first caller that
we have is Norman listening from Toronto
Canada
Norman welcome to the program you're on
the air good evening pastors evening I
have a brief question to say but it
probably has a long answer when Jesus
returns what does the Bible say about
ending poverty around the world because
there's there's poverty around the world
for years and years and it's getting
worse even in American Canada what does
it say when Jesus returns about poverty
will it end well the Bible does say in
Revelation chapter 21 that God is going
to wipe away all tears and there will be
no more sorrow no more sadness no more
pain and it tells us that we will plant
vineyards and eat the fruit of them and
that there's gonna be abundance of food
nobody's gonna be hungry because of
course well you see when Jesus returns
the next time Norman it says the saved
are caught up to meet him in the air
you probably remember the verse it says
in John chapter 14 Christ said I go to
prepare a place for you and if I go
prepare a place for you I will come and
receive you to myself that where I am
you might be also he says in my father's
house are many mansions and so he takes
us back to the place he's prepared for
us we live and reign with Christ and
this a beautiful place called heaven the
New Jerusalem for 1,000 years and at the
end of the 1,000 years we come down and
after the judgment it says he recreates
a new heaven new earth there is no
poverty in the new earth I can promise
you that you know we have a study guy
that deals with what happens after Jesus
comes it's a great lesson dealing with
Revelation chapter 20 called a thousand
years of peace kind of describes the
home that we beamed I'll be happy to
send this to you Norman or anybody you
would like to learn more about that
subject again all you'll have to do is
just give us a call on our resource
phone line 808 three five six seven four
seven and just ask for the study guide
called a thousand years of peace we'll
be happy to send that off to anybody who
calls and asks our next caller that we
have is Alan listening from Minnesota
welcome to the program Helen you there
Ellen in Minnesota
Hamilton Minnesota Oh Peyton is that one
here it's not Minnesota Hamilton Montana
Montana okay we got the wrong state code
there but anyway go ahead be glad you
the ansan yeah Big Sky Country yeah glad
to talk to you guys okay so I got a
question has to do with forgiveness and
Christ is the one that forgives us and
you know you can read our hearts and
stuff but I just wonder if you got any
insight on how do you forgive other one
know yourself well you hear that how do
you how do you forgive yourself well for
one thing if if you died because of your
sin and a new person is born that new
person doesn't have the guilt from the
old life that really helped me because I
did a lot of things I was ashamed of and
when I became a Christian it said you
know the old person dies you are a new
person you get a new heart old things
are passed away all things are made new
so for one reason you forgive yourself
because you've been born again you're a
new person jesus said unless you're born
again you cannot enter the kingdom of
heaven
furthermore if God says he forgives you
can we set ourselves up as a more
important tribunal than God if God
declares look how forgiving we say well
God you know my words more important
than your word I'm not gonna forgive
myself so obviously if God is willing to
forgive us then who are we to dare to
say that our our word is more important
than God's word of course we should
forgive ourselves if he goes to all that
trouble to buy our forgiveness that'd be
like rejecting a very valuable gift
someone bought for you in saying you
don't appreciate it Eydie are you still
with us Alan yeah I'm here did that make
sense you know it does but it don't
because I didn't die to be able to pay
for my own sins only Christ can forgive
myself well you have a chance to die now
though because jesus said you deny
yourself you take up your cross and you
follow him
and then he gives you a new heart so in
that sense you you Jesus said you know
if you're gonna follow him he that seeks
to save his life will lose it but if you
lose your life for his sake you'll find
it so in a sense you you do sort of die
and matter of fact that very book we're
offering tonight I think Alan would
really appreciate the surrender itself
absolutely there's actually another one
Alan you might want to jot this down too
so two books the one the surrender
itself but we have another book called
three steps to heaven
nothing deals with this very subject of
what are we doing we'll receive the
forgiveness that God wishes to give if
you'd like to receive any of those books
just give us a call the number is 883
five six seven four seven and you can
ask for our free offer for tonight which
is the surrender self and also the book
three steps to heaven we'll be happy to
send it to anybody who calls and asks
and he can read that right now at the
amazing facts website that's right just
amazing facts dot o-r-g will give you
more information about that our next
caller that we have is Martin listening
from New York Martin welcome to the
program hi pastor I'm glad to get
through god bless you and my question
was this that Satan and the angels will
say the fallen angels have eternal life
no the the Bible tells us in Matthew
chapter 25 that Satan in his angels in
the judgment are going to be cast into
the lake of fire and the Bible calls
that the second death so the the
criteria for getting eternal life it
says God so loved the world he gave His
only begotten son of course this is John
3:16 that whoever believes in Him might
not perish but have everlasting life so
it's for those that believe in him that
get the everlasting life now the devil
doesn't believe in him he doesn't get
everlasting life he's going to get
everlasting death and his angels mm-hmm
you also have a verse in Revelation
chapter 20 verse 14 it says death and
the grave or Hades is the old English
were cast into the lake of fire this is
the second death so even death ceases as
a result of the lake of fire
only no more no more death following
that the earth then is purified with
fire and the earth is we
created following that yvaine now we do
have a lesson Martin that talks a little
bit about the devil and where he came
from and what his fate will be and it's
called did God make a devil if you'd
like to receive that study guide just
give us a call once again that number is
885 six seven four seven and you can ask
for the study guide called did God
create a devil my next one that we have
is Jerry listening from Oregon Jerry
welcome to the program yes good evening
pastors I was looking at Daniel 7-eleven
where it talks about the Beast being
slain and his body destroyed and then
thrown into the lake of fire now that
now when you read I believe is a similar
account in Revelation 19 20 it says the
Beast and in this case the fault and
this false prophet were thrown alive
into the fire could you comment on this
yeah well being thrown in the fire has a
number of meanings biblically one is
it's talking about punishment the other
is that was the way something was
exterminated if you look in Malachi
chapter 4 it says that all that do
wickedly the days oh let me see here
behold the day comes it will burn as an
oven and all the proud and all that do
wickedly will be stubble the day that
comes will burn them up it will leave
them neither root nor branch and so
those metaphors are used to say that all
the wicked and all that do wickedly
that's the beast that's the prophet
that's the false prophet the dragon
they're all going to be consumed that's
the the Confederacy of Nations because
that's really made up of people God's
not going to be burning flags so I think
it's just telling us that the the wicked
are judged punished according to what
they deserve and that's what you're
reading there in Revelation 19 about the
punishment of Babylon I guess that's a
bastard to duck but again that daniel
says that the Beast is killed and his
body destroyed and then he's cast into
the lake of fire but the revelation
scripture says he's cast
live into the lake oh I see what you're
asking yeah just a few quick thoughts
and then pass it are you jumping there
too if you look at the context of
specifically Daniel chapter 7 the beast
that's referred to there Daniel 7
describes four different beasts
representing different kingdoms the
fourth beast historically from if you
look at the description given represents
Rome now Rome is consistent of two parts
you have pagan Rome and then you have
the papal or the religious side of Rome
which ruled during the Dark Ages in a
very real sense pagan Rome was destroyed
when papal Rome took over and kind of
extended its rule Revelation chapter 19
he's talking about the final opposition
that comes right at the end of time
where once again was revived beasts
power will attempt to persecute God's
people
so specifically Daniel 7 refers to the
fall of pagan Rome while ancient Rome
Revelation chapter 19 is referring more
to the religious component of Rome and
its final downfall in the last days yeah
that's right
I was misunderstanding your question
Thank You Jerry and we have a study that
talks about the beast power don't we we
do it's actually it's called who is the
Antichrist that's the study guide that
goes along with that same theme you can
also read about that in Daniel 7 if
you'd like to receive that study guide
the number to call is eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
and again you can just ask for the study
guide called who is the Antichrist and
we'll be happy to send it to anybody who
calls and asks thank you for your call
Jerri our next caller is Walter and
Walter welcome to the program hello
thank you for having me on my question
was when jesus healed the blind man he
used mud and spit and I was just curious
why he had to do that well it's
interesting jesus he healed
different people different ways I think
one reason he did this first of all that
man is one of the few examples in the
Bible where he was sort of healed in
degrees it says that first he saw men
like trees walking and then he saw all
things clearly
and it's like the Lord held he'll demand
degrees to remind us that God sometimes
heals a person instantly Jesus doesn't
even need to be there he healed a Roman
centurion without even being in the same
town the Lord might heal a person by
speaking the Lord might heal a person by
touching the Lord might heal a person
through medical attention Isiah put
they'd put a poultice of figs on a boil
that Hezekiah had but he said that God
would heal him and he did took three
days and at the same time Jesus He
healed this man through his some
treatment now I think there's some
symbolism there what did God do when he
made Adam how did God make Adam in the
beginning he took the dust of the earth
ground right he took the dust of the
earth he formed the man it almost makes
it smell like you you know added some
water and so here from the from the
mouth of Jesus it usually comes the word
and so the Lord takes mud dust what he
used to create man and then he takes
spit from his own mouth and he puts it
on his eyes I remember when I was a kid
if I smudge in my face my grandmother
would spit on her hand then rub it on my
face I used to think that was so yucky
but hey Jesus is the son of God you know
he's pure and clean and and this was
just something he did to show that He is
God
you know something else interesting
along those same lines there was sort of
degrees in this case where the first he
sees trees walking well Jesus does say
to people when he heals them he says
according to your faith let it be unto
you so perhaps in this case the healing
was not 100% immediately perhaps there
was opportunity for this person to
exercise more faith in Jesus and as his
faith grew the miracle was able to reach
its fullness eventually was able to see
so Jesus at different ways to strengthen
people's faith when he worked with him
did that help Walter that sounds great
thank you so much thank you
alright thanks I'll call our next caller
that we have is let's see she'll be
listening from Kentucky now she'll be
welcome to the program thank you guys
for having me
so my question tonight is okay so I'm
doing Bible studies at my church and now
I've got all the all the you know the
set of study guides from amazing facts
and that's that's what I'm doing them
with right I've got a student then I'm
having a hard time with he is uh he's
talking about visions and you know I'm
doing my studies and I'm trying to help
him and I don't know he just kind of
like throws it off a little bit with
like he says he has these visions and
stuff and I know but the one
still there yeah we might have lost you
shell jelly you're cutting out a little
bit well I tell you what you may come
back in we're gonna leave your line open
for a moment let me just say it is a
challenge sometimes when your pastor and
you talk to people and they say pastor I
had a dream I had a vision what does it
mean you know the bible does tell us in
the last days that God and this is Joel
chapter 2 God can give people dreams and
visions so you don't want to discount
that my experience has been that more
times than not these visions are being
influenced by something else it could be
just a troubled mind it could be in a
satanic it could be medication it could
be a bad night's sleep more times than
not when people say I had a dream and
what does it mean it sounds like they
ate too late so people need to be
careful not to base their conclusions on
a dream or vision but what does the word
say so any dream or vision would always
support or endorse the word and you know
I would get your friend if you're
studying with them to focus back on
saying well that's interesting but let's
get back to what does the word say and
you might even show them in the studies
where it says nothing is more important
than the Word of God that's the first
Bible study so I hope you heard that
Shelly we lost your call and appreciate
your calling in next call that we have
is Lynn listening in Riverside
California Lynn welcome to the program
Lynn are you there yep all right thanks
for calling hi I had a question I
recently had a conversation with family
earlier and they were mentioning hello
and like when someone dies God called
them to the other side for for his work
and I ain't know what the Bible says the
follow-up ends when you die like we
dressed in gravy so Christ um I was just
wondering how how would I be able to
share the truth with others because it
kind of it bothers me to think that
their God takes people for his
yeah well it is it is true that
sometimes God will in his lover for
whatever reason allow a person to go to
sleep to die
I mean he's allowed you know even some
of his martyrs to die there is a battle
between good and evil not everything
that happens in this world is God's will
that's why we pray in the Lord's Prayer
that will be done death is an enemy it
wasn't part of God's original plan and I
think it's in Hebrews is that Hebrews 11
where it says Satan who is the author of
death but you know you need to be gentle
when you let people know that the the
living are the dead rather will live
again in the resurrection when Jesus
comes but the resurrection hasn't
happened yet so the idea that the dead
are all up in heaven like a big balcony
seat watching what's happening here on
earth is not taught in the Bible it says
in the Bible when the Lord descends then
the dead in Christ will rise you know
one thing you can do we have a website
called death truth you can direct them
there we've also got a really neat new
magazine it's called the the ultimate
mystery or the death magazine daf the
ultimate understanding the mystery of
Dan yeah I understand the mystery of
death we got a few different products so
you know that's something you might do
Lynne is get a couple of these magazines
or the study guide are the dead really
dead and share that with them and the
web site death truth com yes great
resource thank you appreciate your call
next caller that we have is Dan
listening from Brooklyn New York then we
have just a few minutes before we take a
break here wow your question a pastor
yes I'm curious your collection and what
Jesus said to his disciples and
companions that isn't in the Bible the
way the Muslims have what Muhammad said
to his companions that isn't in the
Quran because did Jesus actually say it
easier for
a camel to go through an eye of a needle
than for a rich man to get to heaven did
he say that or is it in the Bible yeah
that no Jesus well Jesus both said it
and it's in the Bible
where I said it's easier for a camel to
go through the eye of a needle than for
a rich man to enter the kingdom I think
that's Mark chapter 10 is one it's in
what two or three places where he says
that so yes Jesus said it if there's any
writings of Jesus that you know that we
could establish or substantiate our
sayings of Jesus that are not in the
Bible or I'd say if we know of if
they're sayings if Jesus put them in the
Bible but I don't know of anything that
we know Jesus said that isn't in the
Bible
now the that story specifically is
mentioning mark chapter 19 as well as
let's see mark 10 Luke 18 so at least
two of the Gospels referenced that
account but Jesus said it's easier for a
camel to go through the eye of a needle
than for a rich man into the kingdom of
heaven there is some discussion as to
what exactly that I have a needle might
be but I think the point of it is there
needs to be like we said at the
beginning of the program the surrender
of self unless one is willing to
surrender all for Jesus what hope is
there yeah you and I were in Israel not
too long ago and entering Jerusalem they
had a couple of very small gates that
one man could get through a camel can
maybe get through if he got on his knees
they called it the eye of a needle
because the enemies couldn't get through
it they could plug it real easy with a
big stone and so some of wondered was
Jesus referencing that you could get
into the city but he had to unload like
a camel has to get on his knees to get
through that gate so meaning for a rich
man to get into the kingdom you have to
humble yourself Christ also said is hard
for a rich man and the disciples were
shocked by that they said who then can
be saved and the Christ said well with
God all things are possible and
fortunately right after Jesus says that
in Luke I think it's in Luke 18 and Luke
19 you got Zacchaeus who's a rich man
who humbles himself and he ends up being
able to enter the kingdom of heaven so
yeah there's hope of course Joseph of
Arimathea another rich man you hear the
music friends we'll be right back don't
go away
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
throughout recorded history tales of
ghosts and spirits can be found in
folklore in nearly every country and
culture the Egyptians built pyramids to
help guide the spirits of their leaders
Rome sanctioned holidays to honor and
appease the spirits of their dead even
the Bible tells of a king that used a
witch to contact the spirit of a
deceased prophet today ancient folklore
of spirits and apparitions have gone
from mere superstitions to mainstream
entertainment and reality scientific
organisations investigate stories of
hauntings and sightings trying to prove
once and for all the existence of ghosts
even with all the newfound technology
and centuries of stories all over the
world there is still no clear-cut answer
[Music]
so how do we know what's true why do
these stories persist does it even
matter
we invite you to look inside and find
out for yourself visit death truth
dot-com
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 end will get
through he got a sometimes call back and
lions open and close all the time my
name is Doug Batchelor my name is John
Ross I am pastor Doug we gonna go
straight to the phone lines get as many
calls in as we can we have Wilson
listening from Nashville Tennessee
Wilson welcome to the program you're on
the air okay thank you
my question was like the Book of Isaiah
65 verse 17 and also 20 white speaking
of and you are being created and new
heaven but when you go to verses 20 it
speaks of an old man that has no sin
these days for the child shall die and
100 year summer question was in the new
era will people still be done yeah this
is a place where when it was translated
into the King James it's not the best
word it doesn't say that it's talking
about a child will cease to be a child
it uses word died there because the word
sometimes interchangeable now have you
ever seen a hundred year old child no ok
so right away you know it's talking
about something supernatural or special
if you look in the Old Testament back
shortly after Adam was created the first
few sons of Adam Seth eNOS on down to
Enoch they didn't even get married until
there were over a hundred years of age
and so when he says in heaven because
we'll live so long that those that are
resurrected as children they will not
even cease to be children until they've
reached a hundred did no one's gonna die
in heaven so and there will not be an
old man that is not fulfilled as days
sometimes a person dies and young and
their their lives are incomplete he's
basically saying my elect will long
enjoy the work of their hands it's gonna
be eternity so Isaiah is also using
poetic language here he's probably the
richest poet next to the Psalms in the
Old Testament you still there yeah yeah
yeah so you know we have you have
anything you want to add to that pastor
absolutely I mean that telling us that
children will probably grow a little
slower in heaven but childhood would
finally come to an end
yeah okay and another reason we know the
children will grow up is you read in
Malachi chapter 4 it says they will go
forth and grow up speaking of the new
heaven and new earth again they will go
forth and grow up as calves of the stall
I mean they'll just be free in the
fields nothing to fear so yeah there
will be children in heaven there are no
children dying the word die here should
really be the child will not cease to be
a child even that until it's a hundred
because we have eternity to live okay
thank you all right hey thank you good
question next caller that we have a Zika
listening from Chattanooga Tennessee
Zika welcome to the program thank you
pastor awesome pastor bags bachelor for
taking my call my question is does the
church age heavy and and has an hour did
it
in 1988 why would you ask that question
there was a I don't want to give any
names because I know that God guidelines
but there was a radio station that they
said the church age yeah yeah I think I
know you're talking about
they said the church come on the phone
yeah I have that you know there's
nothing in the Bible that well I'll tell
you where they get it some people say
that with the formation of Israel in
1948 then you add a generation which
brings you to 19 is it 88 then and so
they're saying it is a Bible generation
after the Reformation of Israel that the
church age ended you know that is one
person doing a private interpretation
there I don't know any serious scholars
that believe that and as long as the the
idea of the church age Christ poured out
his spirit there at Pentecost in Acts
chapter 2 there's nothing in the Bible
that says he's withdrawing his promise
and why would we need less of the Spirit
in the last days now this one particular
leader was telling people that you're
not supposed to belong to any Church
anymore well you know they're gonna
silly well why would we not want to be
gathering together with God's people
right up until the Lord comes Hebrews 10
tells us as it to verse 25 forsake not
the assembling of ourselves together and
all the more as you see the Day
approaching
so yeah it's that's a private
interpretation in my opinion that
doesn't have any biblical the other
verse you're referring to is Hebrews
chapter 10 verse 25 and of course in
Revelation chapter 12 it talks about
God's people at the very end of time
refers them is the remnant those who
keep the commandments of God and have
the faith of Jesus so you know Christ
will still have his bride here on the
earth the church and absolutely
horrified and ready for him to come now
we've had a lesson that talks about the
the woman of light yes like the whole
the Bride of Christ and that other irty
yep I'll be happy to send it to anybody
who calls and asks thank you guys for
answering my question Thank You Zeke for
calling yes next caller that we have is
Henry listening from New York
Henry on the air oh yeah hello can you
hear me we can yeah all right my
question is if I if I get married and
the woman that I got married to she
called me ten years later that he was
Betty receivers of authy am I in a
communal doses it's like she is well
first of all sin is knowing to do good
and not doing it if you did not know I
didn't know later
yeah that's first of all you and your
wife have to have a long talk about
disclosure that's that's not good for a
trusting relationship to not disclose
that upfront but yeah of course you're
not guilty of adultery on that front
because you did not know right well I
don't know what the circumstances of the
divorce were so and you know if if she
was converted after that and she
realizes she's made a mistake and she's
committed a life to Christ and sincerely
asked for forgiveness and she's willing
to share with you and say you know we
want to make sure that we don't anything
between us God is able to forgive and
able to move forward
so 10 years later
well maybe she's more conscience is
bothering her and she wants to get a new
beginning achieve she did finally tell
you so that's a step in the right
direction i I see on the television I'm
in his name though these businesses with
these create warts and everything and
this oil is there any way the Bible
stated that debris new wealth and
prosperity yeah well no sometimes they
take there's a passage in and he's
asking about when they're trying to sell
the hallelujah oil or the prayer cloths
and there is a place in the Bible where
it tells us that after the Holy Spirit
was poured out that Peter and the
Apostles were so full of the Spirit and
that they'd even take a handkerchief or
an apron from Paul or Peter and they'd
bring it to people 6:00 and and they
touch them and they'd be healed well you
know first of all we're healed by our
faith never did geez
say my faith made you whole the the
person's faith and so people can still
have faith today and jesus healed a man
he said you don't even need to come to
my house you know I'd always get real
nervous pass today if somebody
advertises you know these this oil
that'll bring healing and by the way all
you have to do just cover you know
packing and shipping and you get it for
discount yeah yeah Jesus never sold you
know healing on that type of thing
mm-hmm
our next call Olivia thanks hopefully
that helps Henry our next color that we
have is cam listening from Milwaukee
Wisconsin yeah cam welcome to the
program hi good evening pastor Doug and
Roz I have a question on Exodus chapter
33 verses 11 to 23 did Moses see God
face to face
yes we did it's like that yeah why did
why didn't sit on verses 20 that God
says to Moses you cannot see my face and
you know something like that no man will
see my face and live well first of all
God told Moses when I pass by he says I
spoken to Moses face to face as a man
speaks to a friend and then it says no
man will see my face and live and then
jesus said no man has seen the father
and so I don't believe that any man can
look into the undiminished face of God's
glory if you look in Isaiah chapter 6 it
says the angels cover their faces and
they cover their feet and in the
presence of God and they say holy holy
holy just the glory of God with holy
angels so when it says God said no man
shall see my face and then he said I
spoke to me that Moses face to face face
to face is it's a metaphor we use for
talking to person personally and God did
speak to Moses personally and Moses
would get done talking to God and Moses
face was shining but he did not look
directly into the undiminished face of
God evidently having an example of
Daddy's way
Moses spoke to God at the burning bush
God communicated directly to Moses and
yet God veiled his glory in the burning
bush and yet he spoke to him
face-to-face so we probably the closest
that we have in the Bible is where God
hid Moses and the cleft of the rock and
passed by and then removed his hand he
could seize form yeah but yeah well
that's awesome just by itself God saying
look I can you imagine seeing the
silhouette of God pass bro hey even if
you're not looking directly into his
face pretty awesome but and then you
have other people like Jacob wrestled
with God he said I'm gonna die for I've
seen the Lord and you have Manoah and
his wife this is we're gonna die we've
seen the Lord well they saw they saw God
the Son often veiling himself as as a
messenger and that happened with Abraham
when he saw the Lord stopped and talked
to him kind of veiled in a form of a
human messenger so hey I hope that helps
a little bit Kim and you know I'm trying
to think we do have a book on the name
of God talks a little bit about his
glory that we yes sent you that might be
a good gift of something to read the
number to call is 883 five six seven
four seven you can ask for the book
called the name of God talks a little
about God's glory we will be able to
send it to anybody who calls and asks
Looby is our next caller listening in
Minnesota
Looby wants the program yeah hello how
are you good thank you for calling yeah
thank you so much I have one question
for you
problem with commandment number five I
marry your father mother yes and here
are the issues they are not statistics
yeah you say you know your parents what
I couldn't hear what you said not to see
their narcissistic okay yeah so you have
a hard time honoring them because you
feel like well no what do you think
honor means oh yeah well
yeah well the word honor of course it
does mean respect them as your parents
when you become an adult it doesn't mean
you need to listen to your parents if
they ask you to do something that is
irresponsible or that is especially if
it violates any kind of principle but
you should always be kind and respectful
to everybody even sinful people even
selfish people even narcissistic people
try to be polite and respectful and I
don't know if your parents are believers
or not they probably think they are yeah
yeah yeah but you so you struggle in
your relationship with your parents yes
and there I'm going to confuse the wig
with commandment number five number five
how to respect them and you know all
right well you yeah with you when you
yeah yeah when their behavior rubs you
the wrong way because they're there they
seem to be in love with themselves or
whatever you know the Bible says love
your enemy and so if you can love your
enemy then you can probably love your
parents and respect your parents it
doesn't mean you need to always listen
to anything that they tell you to do if
you're an adult but you should always
try and be as kind and respectful and
Jesus never said keeping the command
which was easy so when you say I
struggle with it you know most people
struggle with all the commandments
that's why he commands us you know
because the commandments are not just
not stealing it's seek and steal in your
heart it's not just killing jesus said
we think angry thoughts against our
brother it's not just committing
adultery people think impure things and
so it's not just an action it's an
attitude and so just pray that God will
give you more a more loving attitude
with your folks well thank you for your
call Looby and our next caller that we
have is Clayton listening from Brooklyn
New York
Clayton welcome to the program yes thank
you learn fast adult I am something
invited me for years no because I am and
the science field
that okay I'm the explosion trying to
explore space looking for human life
over there but I do not believe there is
life over here if we should reach them I
mean they have seen would that also mean
that Jesus Christ went here to die for
them to earth for this some other form
of redemption well I believe there is
life outside of Earth because of course
I'm sure you believe there's angels that
are good that have not sinned yes that I
know that I know that India yes yeah and
I believe the the Bible says that
through Christ God made the world's now
if there are other worlds I believe
there are they're not sinful you know
Jesus left the ninety and nine sheep
safe in the fold that did not sin they
came to this world is one lost sheep so
you know it's like when you're in a
hospital and a person has a deadly
contagious disease they're quarantined
our world is quarantined from any
unfallen worlds because we've got sin
well then we would never be able to
reach them well that's correct
until until we're in heaven we're not
going to be able to exactly yeah you've
probably something that song before Rock
of Ages where it says if we will soar to
Worlds unknown see thee on thy judgment
throne I know it's not the Bible but I
think most of the great Protestants
believe that God's got other creatures
out there besides the earth and there's
other creations but they're so far away
space is so big I doubt we're ever gonna
get there exactly it says to get some
nuclear it would take like yeah 100,000
oh yeah years at a speed of light
186,000 miles a second consider for a
moment that you know just in our
lifetime people have gone from running
and horses to trains and then to cars
and then two Jet's and then to
spacecraft just imagine how much more
technology God has about how much faster
we're gonna be able to go you know I'm
thinking of a book pass it like dealing
with that I think it's called who are
the sons of God yes referring to those
who met you read about an oath fallen
our job yeah absolutely
Clayton if you'd like to learn more
about
: ask for the book who are the sons of
God the number to call he's 808 three
five six seven four seven and he ain't
just asked for the book called who are
the sons of God
Marilyn is listening from Omaha Nebraska
Marilyn welcome to the program Marilyn
you may have your mute on are you there
Marilyn Omaha going once
Marilyn going twice alright hey she's
here you there thank you very much for
taking my call
yeah Mike my question is about the rich
young ruler or the rich young man who
came and asked about how to get to
heaven if how could he get to heaven and
Jesus only quoted the last six yes man
man and not the first four and why do
you think he did that well because this
man's problem was with loving his fellow
man remember what Jesus asked him to do
he said if you want to be perfect
there's one thing you lack go sell what
you have give it to the poor he said oh
yeah I love my neighbor I love my
brother he said oh really go sell what
you have give it to the poor he said
what what what what no I'm not doing
that and so the way we show our love for
God is by loving our neighbor and that's
in first John so Jesus was dealing
specifically with the commandments that
deal with man's love for his fellow man
and then Christ covered love for God
with what he said to him and follow me
and you will have treasure in heaven
it's kind of sad because the Lord asked
this man to do the same thing he asked
the other apostles to do when he told
Peter and James John and Andrew leave
your nets and follow me he told Matthew
leave your cash register and follow me
he was inviting this man to be an
apostle and he turned away it says Jesus
loved him
that's it doesn't say that about almost
anybody else so the Jesus looking at him
loved him he had something really good
inside but he was just in love with the
world and money okay thank you thank you
I think that makes sense now
alright thanks it's a great question
yeah why did he only call
till the Commandments between man and
man and the other thing he quoted all of
them either I think he'd left out maybe
the one about covetousness right I think
before Christ was ready to talk to him
about his relationship with God means to
him to understand what his relationship
was with this fellow man
angel is listening from Oregon angel
welcome to the program angel Oregon
sometimes when these dear folks are
waiting they they newt their phone and
they're talking we don't hear him hi
there yo yeah yes okay thank you so my
question was in the create in the
patient in the Garden of Eden why did
God punish this instead of Satan because
snakes are slippery no hey yeah I think
that it's because what happened to that
serpent was a metaphor of what God is
going to do to the devil now first God
can do whatever you want with any animal
he can make animals it's interesting
there's snakes that swim in the ocean
there are snakes that live in the ground
there are snakes that live in the trees
and they even got snakes in Indonesia
they glide through the air and evidently
the serpent before it was cursed could
fly now I think it's interesting that
around the world there are legends of
flying dragons in a matter of fact I
think I don't remember you could type it
in talks about flying dragons in the
Bible flying serpents fiery flying
serpents I think is what you'll type in
and there are dinosaur fossils around
the world of these flying reptiles again
picture soars and others and so if some
have wondered if you know before the
before the serpent was cursed if it flew
and there are even some serpents that
have what they call vestigial remnants
of spurs on their ribs and they don't
know what it was for so yeah he he
cursed the serpent because the serpent
the devil spoke through it the verse you
referring to passed it exactly two
verses I we got one in Isaiah chapter 14
29 talks about the flying serpent and
Isaiah chapter 30 verse 6 so that is
interesting
schooler that we have is Ruth and she's
listening from Massachusetts Ruth
welcome to the Pope program hi pleasure
to speak with you well thank you for
calling my question is it's about the
genesis in the beginning the earth was
void and there were water on the face of
the world
yes well and God was above the water my
question is what was the Holy Spirit
doing there
well the Spirit of God was getting ready
to create and God the spirit is part of
that life God breathed the spirit into
man and God the spirit came into man and
or at least part of the Spirit and and
animated him it's interesting not only
do you find the spirit and water
mentioned in Genesis in the very first
chapter you go to the last chapter of
the Bible in revelation 22 and it says
whoever wants to take the water of life
let him drink freely the spirit and the
bride say come and so you've got the
spirit in the water in the last chapter
and you get the spirit in the water in
the first chapter yeah they thoughts on
that it's kind of interesting that one
of the elements that you have that
everything is made from you've got the
earth you've got the air and you've got
the water and when it comes to creation
you got references the water the earth
and the air mm-hmm they are made from
are in our world yeah these is the
living water and and the Spirit of God
so but no I think that I think the mass
of the planet was here and you know God
it was it says the earth was without
form and void there was some kind of
matter here but it was sort of formless
and void it probably looked something
like the moon I don't know just a
chaotic blob and God then formed
and created day and night sent the earth
spinning and the Spirit of God the
Father and the son were all involved in
the creation you know the father is
there you know the Spirit is there and
God said all things were made through
the son and again the Spirit of God
moved on the water so all are there
Thank You Ruth for your question I think
we have time for one more we've got
Robin listening in California Robin
welcome to the program got just a minute
and a half Robin can we ask a quick
question
yeah two of Jesus best friends were
Martha and Lazarus
they lived in Bethany which was about
two miles over from the Mount of Olives
and that was a place where he would
often go as a retreat and has stayed
with him now they had a younger sister
named Mary she sometimes called Mary of
Bethany and many believe that she also
was known as Mary Magdalene or Mary of
Magdala and that it's the same Mary
because I never mentioned together and
she had kind of a bad reputation then
Jesus forgave her and used her and and
because you got Mary and Martha they're
fixing the supper in Meerut Martha is
always running around serving and when
Lazarus died Martha and Mary went and
met with Jesus and pled in behalf of
resurrecting their brother you know it
is interesting to kind of the history of
that there's not a whole lot said why
Jesus felt so comfortable with Lazarus
and and Martha and eventually Mary after
she probably Mary met Jesus in the
region of Galilee in Magdala was
actually a town and maybe it was through
her experience with Jesus that Jesus got
connected isn't Martha and he must have
somehow really clicked with Lazarus
because when well they asked Jesus to
resurrect Lazarus they said the one who
you love yes
that's only used one other time in the
Bible John refers to himself as the
disciple whom Jesus loved and then
Martha and Lazarus said the one who you
love speaking I'm sorry Martha and Mary
said the one who you love is sick so he
must have really resonated with the
family when they had the feast in
Bethany Lazarus was also at that feast
and classist is like Jesus died and was
resurrected amazing story you're welcome
hey listening friends you can hear that
we're gonna be chased off the air go to
amazing facts dot o-r-g we'd love to
hear from you and you can donate keep us
on the air god bless
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
can't get enough amazing facts Bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth field
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vor G at aft vor G
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vor G if you've missed any of
our amazing facts programs visit our
website at amazing facts org there
you'll find an archive of all our
television and radio programs including
amazing facts presents one location so
many possibilities amazing facts org for
over fifty years
amazing faxes share the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world we build churches in India
proclaim God's Word in China and have
sent free Bible studies around the globe
today's program and free resources were
made possible by our ministry partners
caring individuals like you if you've
been blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with a Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air
so the blessings you've received can be
shared with others
[Music]
would you like to know God's plan for
our broken world as revealed in Bible
prophecy
once practical trusted solutions for
your biggest challenges freshly updated
and redesigned amazing facts Bible study
guides provide 27 Bible based topical
lessons with beautiful graphics and
straightforward answers that are
enlightening encouraging and
easy-to-understand each study guide
leads you toward real relevant Bible
answers for the most important questions
in your life how can I have healthier
relationships when and how will Jesus
come again and so much more
don't leave your future to chance
transform your life with truths from the
amazing facts Bible study guides prefer
to watch while you read our brand new
prophecy encounters DVD series makes the
perfect companion set don't wait order
your study guides and DVD set today by
visiting AAF bookstore com or by calling
805 38 7 275 if you'd like to enhance
your study of God's Word
visit our website at www.att.com/biz
[Music]
Iorek DVDs and more to help you get the
most out of God's Word to take advantage
of the offers you've heard on this
broadcast
call us at $887 back so RG did you enjoy
this program make sure to tell your
family and friends tune in next time for
more Bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible questions
you